that wouldn't have happened if it was
[ __ ] big bad bob from the 1900s
vest wearing kelly
god i want a vest so if i wear a vest
now i look like i'm waiting tables
somewhere at a [ __ ] high-end
steakhouse
what's up i'm bobby kelly
robert kelly
sexy bob puerto rican bob
and then just [ __ ] six fat robert i'm
here to answer the [ __ ] internet if
you could wipe one group of people off
the earth who would it be i mean jesus
that i could end my career right now
there's a few
is a [ __ ] few okay i am going to do
this grown men who ride bicycles
that their feet click into the [ __ ]
and they
and they have the [ __ ] outfit if you
have the i don't care if you have the
bike and you're right if you have the
outfit and that dumb thin
hat that has no
it has no i don't know what the f it's
just like a painters hat with the
kangaroo pocket in the back and it has
some type of sponsor that doesn't know
you they don't even know you're wearing
their [ __ ] or they would tell you to
take it off i would love for you to be
wiped off the [ __ ] planet but not in
one swoop by trucks
individually
all day long would you rather everyone
be naked
all the time or clothe all the time i'd
rather everybody be naked so they could
get used to the size of my penis
and it wouldn't shock girls when they
saw it they go all right i get it little
tiny sucker it's a grow another shower
how much money would it take for you to
streak on the field of the [ __ ] 20
million dollars for me to streak on the
field at an nfl game it would take a lot
first of all i've gained probably 60
pounds in the pandemic so the what the
my the bush fat
like where my pubes are the bush fat
has literally
like a volcano lava have taken over the
beach i literally shower if my wife
comes in the shower i turn because i i
know i'll get it back i'm gonna get it
back i'll be back i'll be back but not
right now right now as i stand today it
would take 20 million dollars and you
would never see me again on anything i'd
do [ __ ] poetry in new hampshire who
is the worst group of fans [ __ ] mine
they're [ __ ] mean
they're evil
they [ __ ] call me bad names i
remember
i was doing this ask anything on reddit
for jfl
and they stopped it the lady stopped
goes i wanna this is so mean i go it's
my fans
they're [ __ ] mean [ __ ] would you
rather watch a only softcore porn for
the rest of your life i'm almost back at
that where it really does something for
me b only minor league sports for the
rest of your life i would i'm actually i
would see porn because i'm such a
[ __ ] creep
that
like story does it for me now i like
when they talk and that and then the
like a half of areola comes out and like
lady chatterley i'm [ __ ] into that
you don't know lady chatterley oh my god
it was hbo back in the 80s when they
first started showing they would show
her
her muff
right i think that's what you call it
because it's muffy
and
you know the kid would you know huh
and then you know they would do some
stuff and then it would just cut and
they'd be eating breakfast so garrett
you know
so yeah porn softcore porn [ __ ] it
absolutely would you rather be filthy
rich
in the 1990s or poor now
1900 sorry you know that's the biggest
fear about these things when you watch
people hey read this are you going to
[ __ ] it up nick kidd he didn't have it
really that's [ __ ] up
that's a [ __ ] up fun fact man
just found out somebody who's a
multi-millionaire owns radio shack can't
read his [ __ ] country's awesome
this country's the [ __ ] all right a guy
who can't read owns [ __ ] radio shack
and there's the [ __ ] on a host of
everything and in a great movie drumline
would you rather be filthy rich in the
1900s or poor now dude i would rather be
filthy [ __ ] rich in the 1900s are you
out of your mind i would be [ __ ]
filthy rich in the ninth year i'd have a
vest
i'd have a hat
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] cigar no not like then not like
that they don't make hats invest the way
they used to in the 1900s i'd have
horses i'd have my own horse but it'd
have like gold i'd have [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] sick shooters i'd have [ __ ]
sick shooters i never [ __ ] all dudes
around me which is black they'd all have
black hats black horses black everything
and i would have [ __ ] smoking i'd own
a whorehouse a bar i don't [ __ ] ever
oh my god the 1900s it was [ __ ] i
mean you could do whatever the [ __ ] you
want that was the [ __ ] back then
you could [ __ ] get dude you could get
an argument somebody and go i don't like
the [ __ ] cut of your jib boom and
then walk out and people like make way
now i had to [ __ ] move to [ __ ]
westchester trying to fight with a
homeless guy that wouldn't have happened
if it was [ __ ] big bad bob from the
1900s
vestware and kelly
god i want a vest so if i wear a vest
now i look like i'm waiting tables
somewhere at a [ __ ] high-end
steakhouse
if you were murdered would you be the
most likely suspect who would be them i
know i know don't [ __ ] all right relax i
[ __ ] i'm getting a little nervous
with this one i would say it would have
to be my wife
because i secretly think she's a lesbian
and she wants nothing to do with me and
she's plotting this as we speak
but i [ __ ] it up by not becoming so
successful as she thought it was
and uh i [ __ ] up her plan so she's
waiting for me to get one more hit one
more show one more thing make that money
and then
you'll find tubbo in a bath oh in his
own shitto she'll kill me and then
she'll move on with the life with a nice
nice middle-aged chick with gray hair
and then get cats [ __ ] plants and
move into the tiny house i just bought
her
so there you go that's my wife if i die
make sure you [ __ ] get that broad
because she did it if you could have
an endless supply of anything
what would it be rice i don't know it's
weird i love rice
sorry i'm just supposed to go supposed
to go [ __ ] dirty i know but it's just
i love rice and i'm fat and i can't eat
rice they tell me i can't have rice so i
would just love
nah shut up skinny all right
i just i'm not supposed to have rice
because i'm chubby chubby people aren't
supposed to have carbs rice is a big one
i love rice i'm a big rice or a big rice
person would you rather relive your best
sports moment or your best sex moment
best sex moment what the [ __ ] was that
i got to think about because i know my
best sports moment my best more sports
moment was west medford hillside
uh championship hillside won 10 years in
a row baseball fly ball left field i ran
in
slid on my knees grabbed it
made the catch for west medford to win
the championship for the first time in
10 years the whole team i was like oh my
god it was the best day of my life
and uh the whole team pig piled on me
and i have a fear i'm claustrophobic so
i panicked and i just started screaming
get off me
i can't breathe i can't
and it was [ __ ] humiliating they had
to drag kids it went from this beautiful
moment to this this kid was dying and i
was just crying holding a root beer
walking home alone because my nobody i
didn't have a father at that time and my
mom was working it was just me crying
with boogers
that was my best one yeah
sex is great but not like that how much
money would it take for you to strangle
a puppy yeah around 11.50 i can't you
know what i got to say this i wouldn't
be able to kill a puppy
and it all goes back to patrice
o'neill's joke i don't know if you've
ever heard it puppies have eyebrows
remember patrice's joke he was talking
about people who kill puppies to eat and
he's like man they got eyebrows they can
they can make a sad
he's one of the funniest jokes ever he
goes he goes i think i'm killing it but
he goes i can kill a fish in a second
because they're just like
even when they're dead
they have no eyebrows he said the
eyebrows so i kind of agree with patrice
o'neill god bless his soul i would never
be able to strangle a puppy no way would
you rather wake up to a [ __ ] yes or a
hundred dollars and you've come on son a
[ __ ] under now i didn't have to go
through the process of her getting it
bigger
like it was just big like she was just
blowing me yeah i'd have to go through
the embarrassment no it gets bigger you
just
hang on let me just think it's 100 bucks
you can't even get a good massage i
would say 10 000. i love
it's such a good thing isn't it and it
sets you off in the right way
you don't have any of that evil in you
the [ __ ] is [ __ ] one of the
greatest things that in a [ __ ] like a
brazilian buffet where you flip the card
over and they just keep bringing meat
i don't know if there's anything better
if i would be in the 1900s own one of
those steakhouses and have a chick blow
me every morning before coffee i [ __ ]
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon